well we begin in sudan where right now
thousands of people have taken to the
streets to protest against monday's
military coup major roads in sudan's
capital though have been closed and a
cyber security watchdog says the
internet has also been blocked the u.s
and the u.n meanwhile are calling on
sudan's military not to interfere with
these demonstrations at least 11 people
have been killed during protests just
this week
activists have been broadcasting
messages and mosques urging people to
continue their opposition to the
military's takeover
well how did we get to this point in
sudan the military seized power from a
transitional government led by prime
minister abdullah on monday
general abdul fatter al-berhan has
dissolved the sovereign council that
ruling body was established after omar
omar al-bashir was overthrown two years
ago now
brahan's also announced a state of
emergency he promises to hold elections
in july 2023 and then hand power over to
the elected civilian government still
protests have been held around sudan to
reject the return of military rule
well let's speak to our correspondent
heber morgan she's in khartoum for us
hereby no internet access is patchy to
say the least but what are you hearing
from the streets at the moment
well phone lines have been restored and
it's not clear that that is temporary or
it will be permanent it's been
on and off since monday since the coup
started but we're hearing from activists
on the ground that protests have started
in several locations around the capital
khartoum including khartoum's twin city
of omdurman people are taking to the
streets chanting that they don't want to
go back to a military rule and this is
despite the internet shutdown that has
been imposed since monday now general
abdel fattah al-burhan on the day he
made the announcement of the coup on
monday announced that he will be forming
a civilian transition government besides
the one that has already been dissolved
and that the power sharing agreement
between the forces of freedom and change
coalition and the military is still
valid with the exception of a few
crucial points and that it's uh he's
cancelling the article that says that
the transitional military council which
took over following the ousting of
bashir will be restored so people are
out in the streets saying that they
don't want the military to be in charge
they don't want the transitional
military council running them even if
there's a civilian transitional
government formed even if they're all
technocrats as he had promised there's
also concern for violence nostalgia or
10 protesters have been killed more than
140 have been reportedly injured since
monday's protest uh since protests
started on monday and their concerns
because of the widespread of security
forces on various streets and the block
the closure of bridges and major roads
and the heavy presence of security that
there will be violence between
protesters and security forces so
there's concerns that there will be
death tolls by the end of the day and
that protesters will face violence many
of them say that they're going to try to
try to stick to peaceful protests to get
their message across that they don't
want the army to leave them during this
transitional period yeah but you say
there are these concerns about violence
these are obviously planned protests the
military as you say has been preparing
can you talk us through a little more
about what they've been putting in place
obviously the eyes of the world are on
them
yes indeed so you could see tanks on
many of the bridges that have been
closed by the military leading to the
capital horton now yesterday they
announced that they will be closing all
bridges with the exception of two but
we've been seeing this morning lots of
spreads of us of military pickups
military trucks uh fully mounted with
soldiers and machine guns on the bridges
many of them are spread across major
checkpoints or major intersections
around the capital the road leading to
the army headquarters that has been uh
off limits since the 21st of october
when more pro when there were other
protests um with people demanding that
the military does not dissolve the
government this means we have to go a
few steps back nastasia before this all
started there was a
pro-military sitting in front of the
presidential palace demanding that the
military dissolve the transitional
government and there was a pro-democracy
sitting where tens of thousands also
took to the streets demanding the
military hand over power to civilians
and this was at the height of tensions
between the two sides so there is
concern that the security because of the
widespread security forces around the
capital blocking major roads you know
putting uh trucks with machine guns and
soldiers on board there's concerns that
the protesters and the the and the
soldiers will face each other and
several uh uh international actors have
called on the military to try to
maintain the peace and maintain uh the
peacefulness of this protest that is
expected to be very wide today but it's
not clear how the day will play out
we're going to have to just wait and see
how the military will handle the
protesters who are demanding that they
hand over power to a civilian rule
but as you say ahead of this crew we saw
some breakaway factions from the
civilian protest movement and they were
ostensibly actually being sponsored by
the military just how united is the
protest movement that we're seeing out
on the streets right now
well the breakaway movement uh was from
the force of freedom and change
coalition that is the coalition that led
the anti-government protests in december
2018. now they have accused the central
committee of that faction of that
coalition of being
exclusive and excluding many actors that
that were participating in the protest
against president obama bashir now when
it comes to when you look at the two
sides of the forces of freedom and
change coalition the central committee
and when you look at the forces of
freedom and change coalition the
national na the national charter
alliance as they call themselves they're
both on opposite side one of them is
supporting the military saying that this
is not a coup but rather it's a
correction of the path of the revolution
and the others are calling it a military
takeover a coup because of the
dissolution of the transitional uh
executive cabinet and the sovereignty
council when you look at how united the
central committee of the force of
freedom and change are they were able to
mobilize protesters without internet
with poor
with poor phone lines and communication
so it's it's clear that they still have
the power of the streets despite the
fact that over the past two years
economic progress has been very slow
reforms that people have been demanding
for years uh since the transitional
government took uh over has been very
slow as well but people say that they
understand that because this is a
transitional government there's very
little that they can do and they have to
wait until elections so
it's it's it's a battle of who has more
support in the streets and who can have
a stronger heart
stronger cards when they come to the
negotiating table should there be
negotiations there's been talks of
mediation efforts by the united nations
and by several countries and it's clear
that they're trying to mobilize supports
from the streets as much as they can
should they ever come to the negotiating
table and talk about what comes next for
sudan's transition and we are seeing
those crowds there build on the streets
in khartoum and andermann for now though
we'll be speaking to hibbert throughout
the day thank you hibba let's now bring
in jonas horner he is the deputy
director for the horn of africa project
and a senior analyst for sudan at the
international crisis group he joins us
now from nairobi join us as we've been
saying these are unsurprisingly some
fairly huge crowds and the military
response is obviously not going to go
unnoticed now given the internet
throttling and the road closures we've
been seeing what hiber was describing
there about the presence on the streets
how concerned are you that they're going
to actually crack down fairly hard today
i unfortunately think there's a strong
prospect of that
there have been significant and pointed
warnings coming from international
international actors both in sudan and
the diplomatic community outside of
sudan you know hoping to foresole any
violence that might come about today but
um you know the army has shown its face
on the streets in key centers of hartoum
at least today so far and so we're
really concerned that this may be um the
start of a new phase of violence in all
of this and i i think the other
component that we worry about is a
splintering of the military there's a
vast array of armed actors that are out
on the streets of cartoon and they all
will take uh their orders from different
centers uh and and that in itself holds
plenty of opportunity for
um for for much more chaos and violence
well this coup was really only possible
jonas because burhan and himeti the very
notorious general managed to make peace
with each other i mean he has quite the
reputation for violent crackdowns you
allude there to a potential
split within the military side how
united are they especially with
potential concessions um on the
horizon the
alliance that brought himety and berhan
together or back together really um you
know was was after a moment in which
they were almost at dagger's drone in
early june um but i think the current
agreement that has brought them into
a bit of a coalition is very much short
term in in outlook it doesn't account
for the clear and existential concerns
that exist in sudan that have existed
incidents since independence that really
is pit center and periphery
and really you know those who back
borhan those who back hameti have vastly
different concerns vastly different
interests at the end of the day so this
really is something of a short-term
connection for hermeti and bohan you
mentioned there some of the
international pressure obviously that's
been building on berhan and the military
side and i see he's now saying that a
new government will be led by a
technocrat and there are obviously
plenty of rumors going around but there
are talks also happening behind the
scenes
how likely is it that hamdock could
potentially return to power do you think
uh it's not out of the realm of
possibility hambuck has certainly done
his reputation which had itself been
battered in the last year or two but
he's done his reputation no harm by
taking such a principled stand in not
joining burhan's government in refusing
to dissolve the cabinet uh in the days
before this coup actually occurred and
you have a rather more clear set of
demands that have just come out from a
fairly cohesive set of protesters on the
streets and they're very keen to see
first of all the overthrow and removal
of burhan and hemetian and their arrest
they want to see the end of the state of
emergency and they do specifically seek
the restoration of handok at the head of
the transitional government i want to
ask you a little more about the timing
of all that we're seeing jonas because
obviously there was supposed to be a
transition from the military leading the
council to the civilians leading the
council and that by some estimates was
supposed to happen in november so i mean
the timing is obviously very interesting
when we saw the coup
now given that we're seeing people out
on the streets ostensibly rejecting what
the military is offering where does that
actually leave any kind of transition
well that really is that devil will be
in the details of the sorts of
negotiations that are going on um you
know particularly those currently that
are that are featuring international
actors i think the shame though in many
ways has been you know from the
beginning that there has been
insufficient inclusion of a broader
swathe of of sudanese to provide their
inputs to to offer a sense of what they
would like to see
in both the transition and then in sudan
going forward uh and i think any um
opportunity to incorporate those
interests those voices from the street
those people who are out there uh today
will be out there today uh it is key uh
i think the
form and and main uh stream of
negotiation has yet to really form but i
know the un is working hard on this uh i
know other external actors are working
hard on this and i think you know most
importantly of all there's a lot of
engagement between washington and the
gulf
that is probably the locus of power as
things stand as the internationals try
to support a return to a civilian-led
transition
and those voices on the streets they're
certainly very loud and plentiful today
jonas horner the deputy director for the
horn of africa project and the senior
analyst for sudan at international
crisis group always great to get your
thoughts thanks for joining us jonas
thanks mr